[Music]
here we go all right here the fun part
right here you imagine doing that
without our staff oh no we need the
staff to survive cuz they can read us
yeah oh no doubt they can kind of just
read our line and could imagine being
the heat battle surgery I'm my right
hand man Paul how we doing there Paulie
we good can you give me a little bit
more he ain't saying a word you know you
know right yeah you're right trying to
do it without Jordan her fany pack say
hey do hey
hey 20 years we've had an under I mean
yeah it's okay I know I know we could
never repa him remember it was just me
and you that was it your receptionist
was I good you was great but you just I
couldn't afford to pay a reception that
salary so you know you was overqualified
so I had to let you
go fair
enough yes my two Chow Chows are at
Critter Fixer to help their eyes get
back on the prize
hi hello how you doing I'm fine could be
friends what we got going today I
already know they have entropian oh man
we need to get them up here so we can
evaluate them come here baby I'm here
today with Bentley and Ty they are both
Chows Bentley is very good at showing he
likes other people and he does well in
the ring Tai is a little more skittish
in the ring so it's been a little more
of a challenge to get his championship I
was actually raised with CHS and once
you've had a child you don't want any
other kind of dog so he's the grand
champion he is the grand champion
Bentley Bentley look at him look a nice
little man just like a
lion okay definitely a top when it's
rolling in no question about that we
don't see a lot of chows now and they're
men because they're suspecting of having
in tropy on and it's pretty common in
dogs that have a lot of extra skin on
their face basically your top and bottom
eyelid rather than it closing and they
roll under and when they roll under they
irritate their eye a lot and then cause
them to have some scarring on there
looking at their right eye we're going
to have to remove some tissue but
possibly left ey as well I know more
wants the hair is shaped okay we'll
switch up there some beautiful babies
thank you you are beautiful T been shown
much he has been shown much but he hates
it oh he doesn't like he he doesn't like
it that's too much for you I don't blame
you
man both stay right IR aren't they not
as bad it's not as severe Bentley more
or less in that one eye probably can
take maybe a little bit off the top and
the bottom there open up some we'll talk
about getting them in and getting
surgery done for okay I can definitely
tell we're going to have to remove some
extra skin from those top Lids it's
almost like if you know you're walking
around all day and your eyes are kind of
half open that's kind of where they are
now so we're going to feel better after
surgery because they'll be able to see
better then we can eliminate ever having
any issues as far as corneal abrasions
or anything to the eyes I'm not an
artist so this probably not going to
look anything like a Eye Dr first an
artistic ability I hope you got a good
imagination so eyes there we actually
have to remove some tissue from here and
if we have to do top and bottom we do we
remove that tissue and then we pull them
together and we put stitches in here
it's normally a one day procedure okay
and we can get you scheduled and get it
taken care of for you sounds good okay
mommy going to take you home okay but
you going to have to come back they like
they really don't care do they like
we're done we're done you're done see a
minute my buddy Bentley I haven't done
an entropian surgery but I know it's
pretty common in Chows and I know that
it fixes the problem my only concern is
anesthesia but Dr Ferguson came highly
recommended yeah ready go huh
[Music]
she chilling mhm Milo it's okay buddy
Milo the golden doodle lands at the vet
after one too many jumps for Joy what's
up Dr hes what's happening my man how
you been pretty good how you been look
like you don't grew inch you doing all
right yes sir what's going on this dog I
had just came home and he jumped and
landed on jaylen's arm and he hurt his
front left leg boy I heard him Milo
lying probably three or four times this
morning and he was constantly limping so
I knew right away I needed to bring him
in he's more of my dog but he's a family
dog also we'll play I sit with him while
he eats we just have a strong bond
together so his arm pulled to the side
with all of Milo's weight all right
we're going to walk him down the hall
let's see what we got come on Milo often
times we have to watch our clients walk
because they don't walk in and say hey
Doc I'm hurting right here and right
here so by seeing how he's walking I'm
able to see exactly where he's
Distributing his weight and Survey
exactly where the paint is let's go see
how just come on
yeah it definitely hurt he's keeping his
weight off that left side when you put
the pressure down the head comes up uhuh
you want to keep weight off because it
keeps the paint off and then on a good
leg then he can just walk normal make
sense right yes sir let's see if we can
palp this leg and see where this injury
might be you always start the bottom and
work yourself
up it seems to be in the shoulder I'm
sorry my you always want to make sure
you checking there's no bone fractur so
I'm going to shoot the X-ray and then
we'll look at it together yes sir often
times these big fractures dogs that love
to run around and they can jump and
break a bone pretty easily and I'm
hoping there's not a fracture cuz these
dogs don't stay still it's very hard to
them it takes a long time for the bones
to heal this is the shoulder and this is
the actual bone in the shoulder that it
comes up to the clavicle right the good
news is there's no breaks there's no
problem there right this dog I'm pretty
sure just got a hurt tending man I'm
glad you found it quick cuz I was
worried I need you to say this word Milo
has biceps biceps
tenosinovitis
tenosinovitis you know it took me like
four years of his school before I say
that biceps ten cittis and if you pay
Scrabble that definitely give you about
50 points it's really just the bicep T
that goes right over the shoulder into
the groove it's got really inflamed and
it really is painful but it's better
than having a broken bone by a mouth
that's the tendon you see how you move
see you just diagnosed you a need me so
typically I put a cortisone shot in and
then we going to do six laser treatments
be good as new yes sir now that's the
easy part the hard part is what you got
to do for me what keep me from running
got it yes sir so he's going have to be
on a leash cuz them squirrel No J and
squirrels you want a two we squirrel
Hiatus laser therapy is amazing it
reduces the inflammation and also brings
up the oxygenated blood cells so that it
can heals a lot faster don't you look
handsome so I feel like if the owners
can keep Milo from running around and
jumping on things we going to have a
very good outcome yeah that feels good
huh man that's pretty cool Dr Hodes said
he'll have a full recovery we just got
to keep him from running though so he
can't chase any squirrels or anything so
you know that'll be tough I'm going to
be there for my buddy good to see you
boss thank
you hey little buddy what's up you ready
here oh yeah this came in for you today
we got both syes how many in there we
got 50 of them what am I going to do
with 50 B ring when things like this
happen happen we may have a small
shipment that turned into a larger
shipment than we anticipated some reason
the veterinary police comes through and
trying to figure out what happened why
it happened what this come from Andria
told me that Dr Ferguson uses them in
every surgery oh how many times have I
used the B syring maybe like twice these
are as huge as turkey B we can't asate a
puppet with these I ask for one and
there's a box that appeared with 50 feel
like ask for I didn't ask for so why you
got 50 because it was all they had in
stock and I wanted you to have them if
you
needed I was perfectly fine in my nonb
world and you would have been fine too
if you had just act like you didn't see
them but no I can't you man they don't
the quantity on the
side I'm out I'm out I give up I tell
you what I take half you take half no
I'll take two and you take
48 how are you
oh what no that's too close all
right I know next up is an unexpected
visit from an expectant French Bulldog
what's up y'all hello doctor how y'all
good so we had a St scheduled for Friday
huh we were scheduled for Friday let's
see what we got today we brought in
midnight because we were trying to see
if she was ready for her C-section she's
scheduled for Friday but we just noticed
she was really uncomfortable very
restless so I wanted to bring her in
just to get her checked to see if
everything was okay cuz I didn't want to
have an emergency
situation so what kind of stuff we' been
doing panting digging and her temp was
98.7 all right so what I'm doing is just
kind of checking Serv is starting to
open get some mucus plug we Ain going to
take no chances just shoot a picture let
me make sure everybody lined up the way
they supposed to be all right how many
puppets do you think mcnight has either
five or six six good Gra we'll see I'll
be back y'all and it feels like
Midnight's mucus plug has come out but
I'm not 100% sure that these puppies are
ready to come out so I'm going to shoot
an x-ray because I just want to make
sure that these pups of the adequate
size and they're ready to be delivered
you can actually see the bodies there
I'm going let them reassess that count
come on on in I see five see one two
three four five six his head goes that
way and then that one goes that way but
then there's a skeleton that goes right
there to that one oh we got four
puppies four that's why you're the
doctor not me this one is starting to
come to the pelvis the plug is
definitely open I think we might be in a
little distressed so oh they are I think
they definitely need to come out that
doesn't settle well in your stomach yeah
I think you probably got in some trouble
tonight was a good thing the owner
brought midnight in because I see one
puppy stuck in the pelvis so these
puppies are probably distressed and if
we don't get these puppies out quick
it's a good possibility these puppies
could die
when you wake up you going to have some
babies we go ahead and get everything
ready IC let's get a stetoscope and
stuff on here okay top to me ready to M
all right how y'all looking here we got
towels in that towel warmer incubator
warm let's go timing is everything when
you trying to do this we got to get in
and get out before these puppies become
compromised yes sir let's go to work how
we doing PA good so we're going to
expose the uterus here all right so it's
a uterus full of babies this the one
that's got a problem what you see doc he
got moonium all on him uh-oh he
definitely was in distress come on P
when the pregnancy is stall the puffy
can get stressed and release meconium
and the puffy can get trapped in the
sack of his own poop and get suffocated
all right this one of the problem okay I
got him hey talk to me come on B come on
how that one doing J ni not breathing
yet doc s grab teeth since this first
puppet is having trouble breathing it's
probably that the rest of these puppet
are going to have a problem breathing so
I need all hands on there talk to me hey
CeCe get ready to grab a puppy the first
one good hey talk to
me yes sir some Troublemaker how we
doing that one looks pretty good okay
Jordan we got another one all right
buddy how we doing our job to get these
pups going we want to take a towel and
stimulate them we have syringes that we
used to try to pull the fluid from their
lung so they can start breathing on
their own you want me to take one of
these y take this right here your baby
makeing noise yet no can we like to hear
crying the clock is definitely ticking
they don't breathe and they can't
vocalize so once they vocalize then I
know they're doing good then see this
third one going to be distressed he got
moonium on and everything come on come
on this sh the last one yes this one is
pretty strong that third one was the
worst talk to me a little bit you got
something no crying
[Music]
yet
yeah there we go there we go she's
looking great yeah three girls one boy
everybody's talking now look like y'all
doing something right out there
everybody percolate if we had not made
that call with the C-section it's a good
chance that Mom and those puppies surely
would have di but today is a good day
anytime you deliver some cute cuddly
puppies is a good day good job
appreciate the boss team work make Dream
Work yes sir hi pretty
girl having the faith and the respect in
Dr hajes and Dr Ferguson it it really
makes you more at ease knowing that
they're in good hands always I don't
think I've ever seen a person put
puppies in there that good good job as
soon as we get them home first thing
that happens is we put Midnight in her
comfortable spot the puppies go in the
incubator I set the temperature before
we left the house just in case I'm very
ready for them to come home see you
later all right doc all right
doct
you ready to go back to Mommy what we
got today boss snoop snoop is one of my
favorite dos yeah like Snoop been coming
here forever shoot I've known him the
whole time I've been here let's go check
on snoop snoop hey Snoopy what's up man
my man good to see you you see what's
going on so what's been going on with
Snoop he had a bit of a cough and as you
can see he's got his grow back again
that's pretty big there Snoop we brought
Snoopy into today and we've been
bringing him here to Critter Fixer ever
since he was born he's a real Gentle
Spirit and he's very loving he's just
been a real blessing in our life he's
had a growth on his chest two times and
Dr Hodes has removed it so we wanted to
see if he would be able to do that for
him again 14 years old you're still like
wagon tail and everything how fast would
you say it's grown it seems like it
takes about a year to grow to that size
I want to go look in his chest and we'll
see what we got I'll be right back guys
okay thank you no problem right you big
fella Snoopy he's really having a hard
time breathing worried about his heart
and uh I just don't know if it's
cancerous or Ben it's okay Snoopy Dog
definitely not a great sign when a tumor
comes back in the same spot so I want to
check the tumors in the chest and if I
can I'll get it off willing to do
whatever it take to make sure we keep
snooping
around that don't look great bad huh
yeah some much stuff going on over here
that tumor is that's causing some Havoc
there we got some fluid in our chest
like we're starting to get some heart
disease
oh can you grab some blood just a pre
yes sir Snoop definitely is not the the
best surgical candidate in the World
Imagine doing surgery on a 95 year old
person risky because he has to process
the anesthesia but if the liver and
kidney are okay we're going to do some
surgery I'm willing to do whatever it
take to prolong his life as long as he's
not suffering as you can see when I
walked in room Snoop still was whacking
that tail hey Snoop I actually got his
blood
hey hey his blood were a little bit mine
it looks good in that chest though he is
starting to get a little bit of fluid
from the heart we can do some medicine
there but as far as livering kidney and
anesthesia we all right definitely risk
of doing 14 and2 but looking at the
x-rays and the way it's growing there I
don't know how much of a choice we have
of not doing it we definitely want to do
it we'll give it a shot see if we can
get that out of there if he wasn't still
enjoying life we' probably have to let
him go but if it's pain that can be
relieved we do the best we can for him
I trust Dr Hodes so I'm praying for the
best I just said just stay Clos okay
stay close all right 14 and 1/2 years
old right okay you big fell hopefully we
can make Snoopy feel a little bit better
I mean it's definitely an anesthetic
risk my head starting to get heavy huh
going down but we're going to try to be
quick and pay really really close
attention to Snoopy get Snoopy in
surgery and out as fast as we can boy
nervous I am not going to be the reason
Snoopy ain't on this
Earth
getting do okay heart we fine ready to
start yes
sir get straight to it I'm going to be
fast she definitely don't want to keep
them down long when you remove a tu
sometimes it can be long like a marathon
but I really need this to be like a 100
yard dash you got a 14 and 1/2 year old
dog we worried about breathing Snoopy
also has a heart problem so I really
need Snoop to get on this table and off
as fast as I can not only with
anesthesia does their heart rate drop
you also have risk with dropping down
their temperature how we doing boss
doing good didn't try to undermine this
tumor that's pretty big tumor oh my come
on Snoop ain't in there buddy all right
we got this tomb right there what is it
appears to be a lot pom usually LA pomas
are just really fat or at aost hisory so
you can kind of see a white white pale
looking fat but luckily lapomas can be
benign when they don't have a large
blood supply get my buddy off the table
here how we doing P his body temperature
is starting to drop it's not good last
thing we want Snoop temps to drop all
right hanging there Snoop trying to
close this wake them up on it dog all
right old friend get Snoopy sold up but
it's only half about it I mean I'm still
concerned cuz he has to wake up from
anesthesia hey Sno hey so general
anesthesia is not just a relaxed sleep
there's a lot going on if your
respiratory rate is depressed your heart
is not pumping as well so you get a
lower blood pressure and we dealing with
a 14 and 1/2 your heart it has to work
harder to pump blood around the body so
this is really touch and go he Snoopy
let's go and get him some warm towels
and he's still not quite regulating the
heat prob going to take him a little
minute to come
up so his heartbeat is good but his
oxygen saturation is l
and we just aren't there you got a old
dog that you've been friends with and
you love his family and you've been
watching for a long time and he's not
waking up I mean it's tough hey look up
old
friend I'm just thinking about all the
years with this dog you
know I mean this is part of the family
and know you know you can't help but get
emotional cuz you know if you care and I
care I ain't been doing this as long as
I have you know you get attached to
him wake up
buddy there you
go yeah he coming up definitely a good
sign we finally can Excel scaring
me the last thing I want to do
is be the one that caused
them not to be here spend 14 and 1/2
years with a dog and see him grow up and
I just want ready to let let him go and
I'm sure his own is not ready to let him
go you take wins when you can and
Fortune is a win I'm glad I was able to
to make him better just a good dog all
right buddy you go back to being your
same old
snooping Mr Costello how you hold my
breath well you can stop holding it all
right we did good man it just took a
while to wake up we just Wen getting a
lot of saturated oxygen but uh the
surgery went fantastic thank you so much
and just grateful for every day so he
going to hang out with me for the
weekend but you're welcome to come visit
that sounds perfect hey thanks a lot and
I really appreciate it yes sir all right
byee I know
it I love these little
things ready went to your hotel for a
minute shows Ty and Bentley are ready
for some shy during their entropion
repair I don't did my Sur for the day
I'm up next you up next tag him in you s
he trying to go somewhere
trying what time Lun traditionally
starts about 12 I mean I'm a minute
late I got two dogs you can take one
I'll take one no it don't sound like a
plan what time is it 12:02 I'm 2 minutes
away to
lunch it's like a bear we're preparing
here to do surgery on two child Childs
Bentley and Tai and they have entropion
which basically eyelids are kind of
rolling in cuz they have so much extra
skin around those eyes I've done a lot
of entropion surgery on dogs but a
little bit added pressure this time
because they're show dogs so I have to
make sure that they look great when they
get back in that show ring we have tie
up first let's see what we got to take
away here just the right eye right doc
yep we're just doing the bottom how do
you determine how much it take off you
just so what I do initially is get a
reference how much it want to take so
better to be conservative huh cuz we
don't want to turn an inop on to ex
tropon one thing we don't want to do is
take too much tissue we can create
another problem EG trop on where the
eyelids don't even close enough what you
want to do is remove a little bit tissue
out a time till you feel good about how
much you have removed yep that looks
pretty good there beautiful this the
only one you're doing that's the only
one I'm doing we're going to wake this
baby up and proceed to Bentley I think
Bentley is a little more severe I think
we have to do some work on both eyes I
have no idear what I'm going to have to
do bam did anybody else hear
that they probably laying on the floor
somewhere oh my gosh what you see both
sides I'm going do both right and left
yes so now the has removed it gives me a
better visual I can pinch a little bit
to see how much I need to take off I can
tell that we're going to have to do both
eyes on Bentley just triming skin trying
to see how much I want to remove cutting
and just eyeballing it eyeballing it you
have a joke book laying around yeah can
you return
it crack myself up we starting on side
number two going to be a little bit of
everything right dentist
anesthesiologist oh that's true plastic
surgeon today yeah I guess so
so I think we got enough tissue removed
now suit you this back up all right big
Bentley good job doc everything went
well Bentley tropon was a little bit
worse I actually did both sides you can
see those eyelids they don't roll under
the rest of our life we wanted to worry
about eye irritation from eyelids or
anything like that once that swelling
and inflamation subside next few days
they going to look beautiful right here
mom's in here there you
go go oh poor babies I know you can't
get to me that kind of hurts oh yeah
they take your shins out with those they
can do a lot of damage with those so be
careful everything went well they look
real good all right thank you so much
all right I'm very excited to be taking
them home I'm looking forward to how
much better it's going to be for them
when they're able to see clearly next
show is not until December so I'm hoping
that the hair will have grown back by
then hopefully in 2 weeks this will be
just a blur I want to go side let's
[Music]
go Slow Down slow down all right what's
going on with him man he was running and
came in contact with the car that ain't
good kind of got shot of breathing it's
a little
rough oh boy shoot me an x-ray right
quick yes sir a chance left the yard and
the truck was coming one way he was
coming the other it's rough to see him
there trying to breathe as he family we
took him to a hospital they decided that
his injuries were more than what they
could handle and they suggested that
we'd see Dr Hodes today
shooting give me two
seconds that's crazy toe long is
collaps the whole diaphragm is ruptured
somewhere around here it's bad huh it's
is bad man come on in the stomach is
actually in the
chest so what do you do you pull back
the stomach you can pull it back Sutra
but the problem is means the diaphragm
is ruptured so once I open the atomen
there's no more negative pressure the
lungs no longer get inflate so we
breathe for the dog during that time and
that's the tricky part and I can sit
here and I just took a breath I didn't
have to breathe cuz my diaphragm moves
up and down this dog has no diaphragm so
once I put him on the anesthesia what we
call negative pressure where it's G it's
gone and hopefully I'm able to suture up
this diaphragm fast enough before it
dies of a fixation I mean this is a high
RIS High reward surgery the outcome is
either this dog is going to get
remarkably better quick or it's going to
die I'll give you 25%
chance part of the family right here so
we're going to do whatever we have to do
to keep him here as long as we can we
trust
you chance was a rescue dog he rescued
us when we needed it he's always around
even when I'm feeling down so now it's
our turn to return the favor for him we
going to be on it thank you okay let's
go and get him right to go we got this
dog this is that that one million case
where you got to have a little bit of
look for it to go well I mean in this
dog's whole longest collaps the
diaphragm is missing this is probably
about as tough as it gets this dog could
definitely die during this procedure all
right buddy let's do it he going to be
all
right this ventilator is what's going to
breathing for the dog while I repair
this thing when I make this incision
ain't going to be no more negative
pressure all right here we go making my
cut a lot of bruising oh goodness
typically us didn't know where
everything is but in this case the
stomach and the liver has completely
gone in laying beside the lungs this is
a mess how we doing we're good we're
good so the stomach is now coming out of
the diaphragm now making them Headway
yeah nearly Out of the Woods though I'm
trying to get the liver out of the chest
every time I get close the liver keeps
getting sucked up oh wow every time I
move the liver and try to get it out of
the thorax as the long expand it suck it
back in so it is tough come on now it's
so hard because it's such a small space
all right the liver and stomach are back
where they belong now let's get this
diaphragm shut you just did to h a lot
of gurgling come on dog hang now get him
out table I'm trying bro here's the hole
let's Sushi this thing up we need a
miracle hang in
there got it I got a seal I can feel
that diaphragm moving now it's pulling I
think we got him it's the miracle we
needed let's wake them up once I get
those Tes in I'm able to keep the
stomach and a liver lobe out of the
thorax and we get a diaphragm sewn up
you know we're still not out of the
woods but it definitely feels was a
whole lot better boy it's a long day
boss yes sir so how we looking man we
off the table we got that diaphragm wall
back okay I mean we still not out of the
woods but we going put it prognosis
950/50 so we got a shot thank you Lord
so D chance will definitely be staying
here tonight at hotel Hodes and we'll
cross our figures that's all we can ask
for thankful thankful
thankful hey Tak in my special
oxygen it's a bright morning for
midnight the French Bulldog who's back
with her bundles of
Joy what's up girl hi you all right yes
sir these puppies look amazing let's
take a PE than his always smiles when
there are puppies in the house that's
Brock what's up Brock and these were
puppies that I had to save via cering
section so it's always good to get a
follow up and see how those puppies are
doing that's Sasha oh Sasha you can't
get away we'll check to make sure their
belly buttons are what they supposed to
be your belly button is good you looking
for Audi or basically the they don't
have umbilical hernas or any kind of eag
no Hern you always want to check for H
murmur also you want to you looking at
the eyes the ears you know you just want
to make sure they happy healthy puppy
there some sharp te Little
Fangs they look fantastic thank you Dr
haches knowing that everybody is amazing
I am feeling super blessed to watch
midnight and the puppies mature and grow
and come into their personality and
learn how to play with other dogs and
how to play with each other it's very
heartwarming come on
midnight come
on they putting a cape on my back I feel
like the Jan
[Music]
Brown yeah the baby it's Mommy's little
baby hello hello how are you look at you
hanging out down
there you doing okay today they not
really that's why you here huh this is
Melissa an Missy is the princess she is
quite bossy she is telling me when she
wants to go outside when she wants to
eat when she wants to sit in my lap but
right now she's so lethargic so I just
wanted to come and make sure there's
nothing wrong with her she's been up on
her front paws lifting her behind ups
when her tummy hurts any vomiting any
diarrhea no diarrhea but she throws up
okay so we didn't sleep last night and
we didn't sleep Sunday your both tired
huh I am Miss is not sleeping which
means the owner is not sleeping so I
definitely feel for her all these
symptoms are very serious and I have to
put this detective hat on so they can
all get some rest it's okay she not
going to leave you I would never AR
sounded good how old is she now Missy is
eight okay are you hurting somewhere
sometime they can have
pancreatitis and they'll get in a prayer
position because they're getting the
pressure off the pancr and it feels
better oh cuz she's been doing that a
lot so I want to run a couple tests here
okay they have pancre titis they have to
be hospitalized hopefully they're
negative I hope so too I can't sleep
without a now we might have get you a
bed up here huh yes I'm serious I got
you all right we're going to do we can
pancreatitis is an inflammation of the
pancreas and it can be something that's
very severe so there are a couple tests
that I want to run to either rule things
in or rule things out good girl Missy
because we're 8 years old we're going to
check the liver function kidney function
to make sure they're good as well worst
case scenario we are dealing with panre
titis or some kind of cancer the GI TR
let's go back to your mama I get you
poor baby poor thing it's going to be
okay hey sweet girl it's going to be
okay so we ran a few tests here okay you
don't have to be scared come on over
here okay yeah okay so we start here
with our test which is our CBC and right
now it's normal our next group liver
function kidney function whether we have
diabetes that's normal okay and the next
is our CPL test or the test we test for
pancreatitis it's a color indicator test
the test here has to be darker than the
control or the same okay and you see
it's lighter so that's a negative chest
yay missy we basically left with
gastritis going on that's probably why
we vomiting some but it's probably
hurting painful as well yeah gastritis
is inflammation of the stomach and it
causes a lot of gas which also caused
them have a lot of discomfort we're
going to go on antibiotics especially
formulated for the GI tract some
anti-inflammatories to help for pain and
this baby should be feeling good here in
a few days all right so we happy so you
don't have to stay so you don't have to
be nervous no we don't have to stay oh I
should be talking to you then so we
don't have to stay so we don't
have all right then thank you thank you
missy does not have to stay all night
she does not have pancreatitis so I
can't wait to her to become her bossy
little self again I'm going to give her
that first dose of medication and we're
going to lay down and take a nap
cuz we have not slept we ready you go
home aren we
[Music]
sugers did Dr H just respond he called
me and I told him just few seconds ago
yeah okay after a weekend of recovery
for Snoopy the dog Dr hajes rushes to
the clinic as an emergency arises when
he start signing Weezy this morning
Snoopy he kind of crashed on he went
into labor breathing it got very shallow
so we put him on oxygen his temperature
dropped I hope for his sake and Dr hes
that he making cuz Dr H is very attached
to this dog he going to be
devastating hey h Snoopy's family just
got
here he ain't going but he just I think
he just this his heart so I let you see
him hey s somebody here to see you hey
buddy he saturated off and everything
it's 68% I could tell he's breathing a
little harder we need to make decisions
not yet no let give him some time I'm
looking at Snoopy's saturation of oxygen
which basically means the heart beats
and it puts blood around and the body
gets profused with oxygen to make the
brain go you have enough oxygen to make
the lungs go but with his age and heart
disease to everything he's going through
their body just sometimes just isn't
able to recover so more so than the
tumor heart disease 14
[Applause]
I don't know
Snoop his heartbeat is getting weaker
hey go ahead and put a blanket in there
I mean the way it's going I want y'all
to be with
him it's really tough to see Snoopy in
this state you
know you know as a veterinarian you got
problems that you wish you could fix and
unfortunately looking at Snoopy I kind
of realized that this is probably it
y'all come on over here cuz I think he's
starting to take his last few
sorry we have to let him go suff give
him something I don't want him to
suffer thank
you I'm used to Dos coming out of my
favor but his body just kind of gave out
him you know I guess it's a part of life
I know you guys did a lot for him so
thank you it's all good he's special
this dog is like a lifelong friend you
know I know it's not fair but I got
people in that room who almost like
family and my job is to be strong for
them you love them too I love
them I did I love them
too it's hard sometimes some of these
pisss we saw them at Birth they're like
your children you saw them literally
grow go through their issues and then
you right there with them when they take
their last breath you know it gets tough
you also have to treat the owner as well
you know they have the emotional
attachment it's definitely not an easy
thing but it is a blessing that we had
an opportunity to be a part of their
life all right who we got
[Music]
next
oh man a petite puppy is in for having
an unusual appetite hey hey how you how
you doing who you got here yeah island
girl what's going on with island girl
man I had little out of a cage and then
she swallowed a sock I seen one so then
I turned around again I seen her grabb
one little bitty sock think she got two
socks oh my she came from the Virgin
Island so I was like okay I'm going call
Island Girl basically this my daughter
dog so I let her just play with her the
day she was grabbing the stuff off the
sofa and stuff like that that and then I
kind of seen like he did she just eat a
sock I just kind of figured she couldn't
pass no socks so you know I had to get
her here quick as I can you know make
sure she all right did you see any vomit
diarhea or anything no she was still
running around playing yeah after she
ate the two socks yeah she was looking
for another one oh my give me one second
boss all right anytime a dog possibly
ate a foreign object that is really
really bad these objects can make
intestines rap on theel and they can
just get physically stuck and it can be
fatal he said I don't want to lay down
typically one of the first things we'll
do is uh x-ray because radioraps tells
us where's this thing lost and exactly
what is in
there uhoh no one on there's a whole
bunch of stuff in there how you eat all
them
sauce B all of
this sock it's soof yeah my game plan
I'm going go down with an endoscope and
I'm going to see if I can grab them
almost like that claw game and just try
to pull them out one by one appreciate
it man I'm going use my end the scope
and hopefully be able to go down and
retrieve it if I can't we're going to
possibly have to go to surgery you know
what you did she said it shouldn't have
been in the floor but when you cut the
stomach that opens up a whole other list
of problems you got possible leakage and
you worried about possible sepia so I'm
really hoping to avoid going in with my
surgery blade he only ate socks right he
ain't ate no toys we F to find
out yeah you getting sleev yeah
endoscopic has been around for quite a
bit in human medicine and not so long in
veter medicine takes a learning curve
I'm operating in a space about this
small inside the stomach so I got to go
up down look and be able to retrieve it
but I'm thinking all those years playing
video games definitely help all right
let's see what we got going on in
here we have food everywhere food so she
had food to go with them socks so as we
start going into the stomach I noticed
that this is a very hungry pup it ate
one so then it ate another so then it
even ate a meal afterwards this stomach
is fill but just like this puppy I have
to dig in just a little bit more I don't
think that's food that's a s one all
right Paul let's send in the clock yes
sir Ferguson missing all the claw game
today come back a little
bit let's bring P
it I don't see nothing I got it
feel I still got it one done one to go
boss how you eat a whole sock have no
clue we see a lot of things inside our
animal's stomach and usually they chewed
it up some but this sock is coming out
fully intact I mean she just ate the
whole thing whole so what are the odds
she inhal the other one all right we're
back in the stomach let's see going a
little bit more a some chunks she
swallowing food ho she just you know
everything what's that I don't know is
that piece over there a purple sock
ain't it oh that's what that is purple
sock oh wow okay it's a big sock oh yeah
you want it
ready there we go woohoo that's two you
think the third one no no no it was two
of them do you want these no okay good
to go man dog wake up tomorrow it'll be
like nothing happen I appreciate that
man I knew where to come I've gotten a
second sock Out and because I use the
endoscope I don't have to worry about
any kind of leakage from my Suite she'll
be back to her old self tonight and be
ready to play around on but stay away
from socks hey you cannot eat this no
you not learn your lesson can I get a
comb for this dog and you trying to eat
his CA oh my goodness now you want to
eat my M no
hey what is wrong with you you got a
problem you got to get the cor of Shame
you need to be a good girl so you have
literally gone down in history never in
all my years have I had to put the cone
of shame on the animal I did no surgery
on con of Shame Hall of Fame I feel good
man I knew they was going to do a good
job man so I I wasn't even really
worried Dr he is like he's the best I
think me and probably get something to
eat cuz I Ain had time to eat yet either
so we probably get some I get her some
like some snacks or something I know she
might be hungry a little bit so took the
socks out of
her they s real good don't it hey how
you feeling chance Dr Hodes evaluates
chances chances is following the dog's
risky surgery all right come on paie
what you got going what you got can we
take an x-ray on chance M it's been
about 3 days since Chan's surgery and
I'm definitely happy to see his bright
and alert but I really want to take an
x-ray to see if the diaphragm is holding
and see if the lung has inflated
shooting what you think doc the collapse
long on the left side is doing very well
and that diaphragm is definitely they
holding chance pulled through so Chance
is going home it's a lucky dog he is
indeed it's very satisfying as a
veterinarian when you can take a case
that has some really really impossible
odds stacked against us and you know and
you win so the pet wins the only win so
it's just a win win win all the way what
you think Chance yeah chance with the
prce the prognosis for a chance is
really really good he's breathing better
he's eating he's going to the bathroom
so I'm super happy to be to send chance
home with his family cuz they really
miss him look who it's
going hey hello boy see the bruising is
better yes it was red all the there I
mean we breathing much better we wagging
our tail talk about a miracle yes siring
back waging his tail he made it through
he made it through this is why I do it
though I mean sometime long nights this
makes it all worth it
you thank you
we came here to give chance a chance to
make it and look at there we're we're on
our way home now so I'm I'm exatic just
want to personally thank Dr hajes before
really giving chance a chance and then
giving us the one that we love back to
us so glad to be going home not
empty-handed yes ma'am I wasn't going to
give up so happy you ready to go let's
go it's a
miracle the docs take a well- earned
break from Critter Fixer to throw a
mixer for their
[Music]
staff look at that I don't want to do
that this week is vet tech appreciation
week and this is the time we use just
let them know that we really appreciate
everything they've done you got long
arms I thought it was going to be easy
we brought them here he want them to
have fun away from the clinic anytime we
have an opportunity that we can give
back to our employees we're going to
jump at that chance it's just good to
have them out and just having a good
time you got it
nope
let's go let's go let's go you know
without our Tex wouldn't be a CRI their
job is definitely not
easy every day is just a host and Bast
everybody running around administering
the medication pulling the blood running
the test it's all done by technician
they really need accolades 52 weeks a
year you know those oxgen cages we have
a CRI I need
[Music]
one we had dreams of being successful
veterinarians but there were not be
possible if it was not for you guys we
really do appreciate you can we got
everybody a special gift come on
Andre fix
special we had to find something to do
with them Thanksgiving is coming soon
nobody that crifix will have dry turkey
for this
Thanksgiving you're seeing everybody
having fun and not in the clinic and not
thinking so much or stressed on a case
that's what it's all about it's always
funny
Happy
B happy T Day to you all
[Applause]
[Music]
right